hello good morning we start with
breaking news the BBC chairman Richard
Sharp has insisted this morning that
there was no conflict of interest in the
decision to appoint him to the role it
follows his alleged involvement in
arranging a loan of 800 000 pounds for
Boris Johnson a government investigation
will now look into Mr Sharp's part in
discussions between multi-millionaire
Sam Blythe and Boris Johnson a few weeks
before Mr Sharp was announced as the
government's choice for BBC chairman
well this morning Mr Sharp spoke to the
BBC we had a discussion with the cabinet
secretary about avoiding conflict and
the perceptual conflict I felt
comfortable and I still feel there was
no there was no conflict because at that
stage and what I was seeking to do was
ensure that the process was followed
exactly by the book and that they had
the process hadn't started of any kind
in terms of any support that Sam was
going to provide to the prime minister
well our political correspondent Ali
Ford skews in Westminster for us and Ali
just remind us of what investigation is
actually now going to be going on into
Richard Sharp's appointment so two
probes into Richard Sharp's appointment
one from the BBC itself another for the
commissioner of public appointments who
looks at how ministers appoint people to
public office so two investigations but
as you heard there the chairman of the
BBC being interviewed by the BBC itself
always a slightly awkward Dynamic but he
is very clear
um nothing to see here is basically what
he's saying all of this of course just
remind people about his links to the
former prime minister whether he helped
Boris Johnson secure a loan guarantee to
the tune potentially of 800 000 pounds
in the weeks before he became BBC
chairman he said he was just Connecting
People connecting Boris Johnson to a
distant Canadian cousin
um but of course a lot of people saying
that this is Raising questions about the
impartiality of the BBC and the way that
that process works you heard him in that
interview he says that he took steps to
make sure that due process was followed
and then the cabinet secretary was aware
there has been some spotlights worth
saying on Simon case of cabinet
secretary he of course has been the
consistent throughout Boris Johnson Liz
truss and Rishi sunak's premierships
questions about whether he has done
enough
um and here Richard Sharp saying that he
had been made aware he's making clear
he's not going to stand down as chairman
of the BBC we're saying some people have
pointed out that in the past for example
under Tony Blair Gavin Davies became BBC
chairman his wife worked in Gordon
Brown's office the then Chancellor at
the time so plenty people saying the way
that the BBC chairman is appointed is
often a little bit murky but all of this
of course I think
um just again suggests that
well-connected people in Poland politics
are helping each other out the murky
world of political appointments that is
bad for Boris Johnson bad for Rishi c92
and not a great day for what Nadeem
zahawi yeah still pressure on him his
role as the chair of the conservative
party over his tax dealings
that's right Nadeem zahawi still imposed
the um holding response from government
at the moment the firewall that they are
relying on is that the ethics advisor
has been asked to look into Mr zahawi I
think you know again with this story as
with the BBC chairman in a sense a
person that does have questions to
answer is Boris Johnson he was the one
who appointed Nadine zahawi as
Chancellor but the shadow of previous
administrations is hanging over Rishi
out because remember he is the one that
stood on the doorsteps at Downing Street
said that he was going to change the
course restore trust and we have Gavin
Williamson sacked over allegations of
bullying Dominic Robb justice justice
secretary under investigation over
bullying alludigations now Nadine zahawi
that makes it difficult for Rishi sunak
to say that he's changed the course
labor of course saying that these are
the same old faces the same old sleeves
I think perhaps the most damaging thing
thing maybe for ishi sunak is that he
has faced a challenge to show that he is
not out of touch he of course is a
millionaire the husband of a billionaire
the fact that this is being seen as a
small mishap potentially four million
pounds being paid back to hmrc a one
million pound penalty four million
pounds rather one million pound penalty
as is being reported that being seen as
a small mishap I think will bewilder
people given how much money we are
talking about and again sort of adds to
the sense
um that it is one rule for them one rule
for everyone else and that is
potentially very damaging for the prime
minister